after months of production issues that  thing you love is finally out well is it  worth the hype no that thing you love  destroyed the future of things and love  that thing you love may not be the  absolute worst it does some interesting  things in the third act and is  borderline experimental everyone agrees  that thing you love is a certified  masterpiece that thing you love is bad  objectively and we once agreed on this  as a society so well what is happening  can we just admit that that thingy loves  fandom is legitimately toxic and really  good things are being overlooked because  we keep talking about it for instance  that thing i love